foreign
[Music]
Hall I am going to be speaking today on
the experience of being the only Ru
workplace um I'm so excited to give this
talk I'm so I'm not there in person it's
the plan um but I do have to give a
special uh thanks and goes to the
conference organizer so definitely
handled um my very last minute uh switch
to presenting instead
um the team I suppose formerly known as
the r Studio
these great top graphics for us
um but there is not quite enough self
for my taste um so feel free to follow
me on Twitter
um but really I just want to thank you
all so much for watching Mock and I want
to give kind of a special shout out
welcome to anyone who might be watching
virtually I've been watching this
recording when it's posted later maybe
someone who's even a little earlier
um in there are journals and because
this talk uh is also for you there
should be time at the end clock for
questions um if any come up while I'm
speaking um you can put them at
slido.com with the hashtag CA or I'll
also be around the Discord server this
afternoon if there's any topic that came
you want to chat further about
so this is my laptop
um it probably looks like a lot of your
laptops out there uh but to me this is
the most special laptop of all because
this laptop is why I learned r
um to set the stage a little bit I've
been working as a data Professionals for
over seven years in higher ed
Administration I currently work at Brown
Bruno
um as a data manager
and in that role I am really kind of
this data person in a functional
business office I don't work in I.T I
don't work on a data team a lot of other
data fluent people around me and as you
can imagine
um mine is Excel mostly and so kind of
at the beginning of my career I was also
using Excel for my data analysis because
again that was the atmosphere that I was
in
and then a few I started getting into
hockey and because I am a numbers person
whatever other euphemism you prefer to
use for nerd I pretty quickly started
gravitating the analytics side of the
game started kind of getting involved in
the public Sports analytics community
and as I started embarking on my own
analysis I started using Excel because
that is what I was like most recently
familiar with so what I used to work for
a lot of the data analysis work that I
but let me tell you this lovely laptop
that you see here that I still have and
still uh this 2015 MacBook Air could not
handle Excel files that had over a
million just didn't work it would crash
it couldn't even like filter couldn't
even do basic stuff
um so out of technical necessity
um I started learning R I had been
somewhat with r and SAS and stata
um back from grad school but decided to
pursue learning R because truly it
seemed like it had the most welcoming
and kind of inclusive community and it
seemed like something that was really
learnable to me
and so this experience that many of you
are probably familiar with I've been
happier when I was doing my data
analysis with r as R is much more suited
to that type of data analysis work than
Excel is but again even though I was
very happy using R for the kind of the
sports analytics work that I was doing
on the side it took me a little while to
incorporate all of that our knowledge
into my uh work and the work I was doing
for money because again as I said no one
around me uh was using R so it didn't
seem like a very welcoming environment
to start using it
so I realize I don't need to spend a lot
of time preaching to this crowd that R
is great because we all know that R is a
really Ideal tool for dealing with
reproducible data analysis right and one
of the things that is kind of magical
and amazing about R is that you can use
R for your entire data analysis workflow
but I would argue that kind of equally
amazing is you don't have to use R for
your entire data analysis workflow that
might work for a lot of people but it
might not work for everyone might not
work for you if it doesn't fit within
kind of the constraints you might have
upon you at work
and again I think it's I would argue
that it's like equally great kind of an
equal strength of r that even if you
just kind of use bits and pieces of our
incorporate them into your work that
really helps solve your specific
problems you don't need to use the
entire again A to Z workflow of R in
order to get those benefits of R and so
you can really just focus on what is
possible for you and what helps you
um because it's it's for sure true that
there are struggles
um to incorporating R into a workflow
that might not feel very welcoming
toward it
um but I'm going to today I'm going to
talk about some of the struggles that I
have faced going through that process
how I've handled those struggles and how
I still think they are greatly
outweighed by the benefits you get of
using R again even if you can only use
bits and pieces of kind of the entire
our ecosystem
so I hope that this talk will be helpful
and inspiring to you whether you are you
yourself are kind of starting to think
about using our at work whether you're
like me and like a lone wolf
um using our work and trying to kind of
spread the gospel and looking for some
tips about how to make that job easier
or maybe even you're involved in like
helping usher other people along similar
Journeys along how to
um how to incorporate our into their
workflow so hopefully this will give you
some tips on that
so in addition to my work in higher ed I
also spent some time at zealous
analytics which is a sports analytics
company
and there I worked as a data scientist
among a team of other data scientists in
kind of a you know software development
team
and there are my entire workflow that I
worked in was in R I was able to within
our you know write my SQL code directly
connect to the databases to pull the
data that I needed the products I
created were in our markdown all my
analysis my visualizations Etc and of
course everything was controlled you
know through git and Version Control
and if you work in kind of a traditional
data role in a data team that does not
sound foreign or special to you at all
um but I can tell you that not all of us
are so lucky
um it is true that not everyone gets
like the luxury of choosing their entire
Tech stack but again if you work in a
role maybe slightly less traditionally a
data role or a data role that's kind of
embedded in a lot of non-data people if
you work kind of far from other Tech
friendly folks your options might be
your kind of tech stack options might be
limited and not ideal
which was certainly kind of my
professional case so while going through
a couple of examples I'm going to focus
on my two best tips for dealing with
that problem which is firstly to always
try be creative do as much in r as
possible as less as possible in other
tools and focus on what is really
realistic for your situation not what's
maybe ideal for the general population
someone in a more traditional data
science role
so perhaps you can't access data through
R I am very familiar with this problem I
cannot access my data through our I
cannot connect directly to the databases
that hold the data that I need I have to
use a another external Oracle like
report Studio software in order to
access this data and so here's how I
have finally um decided how I could
developed a program to help handle that
so this is not a unique idea but anytime
I open a new rstudio project I
automatically set up some files that I
always use
and my setup file is really devoted
specifically to all of my kind of report
decisions
so again the report the reporting
software through Oracle that I have to
use is pretty powerful it allows you to
you know make calculations create new
Fields you can write SQL do some pretty
complicated filtering but I again prefer
to keep all of that stuff in r as much
as possible so I can control change more
easily reproduce the code that I want
and you know write that code in the
language that I want to write it
So within my setup files I document all
report decisions like the name of the
report where the report was located any
dates filters Etc and I also make sure
that those reports themselves are pretty
broad population parameter-wise I'm
mostly dealing with people data and I
know that when I want to go to my next
steps and analyze the data I need to
create new fields and filter Etc but I
try to get the biggest possible
population but kind of the simplest
version of the report that I can run in
this external software so I can do again
all the data manipulation work in our
again where R is successful
and this is just a very simple example
of what one of those
um one of my setup files might look like
they always start with lots of comments
again the when where why how of the
report and it's also just a convenient
place to again read in all of my data
you also might need to dashboard
elsewhere
if it were up to me all of kind of the
end products of my work would either be
in you know our markdown or quarto or
shiny or something like that but I work
at a tableau organization I have to use
Tableau you know it can be a little
dicey I'm mentioning Tableau at an R
Focus conference especially when I know
there's a shiny talk going on at the
same time right now but it is a
necessary tool that some of us need to
use
and anytime I have a project that
involves any kind of dashboard component
I automatically create a dashboard file
and if you're not familiar with Tableau
Tableau actually is have some pretty
Advanced capabilities when it comes to
dealing with data you can handle
relational data you can look at data at
different levels of detail aggregations
calculations Etc that's all fine and
good but again I would really prefer to
do all of that data prep work in R where
I prefer the language I have all the I
have all the code in one code file that
I can much more easily change track
reproduce rather than having them kind
of scattered all about the Tableau
Software as it is so again within this
dashboarding file that I create if I
know I have a tableau component to my
analysis project I make sure I have all
the code I create kind of extra data
files at different levels of aggregation
that I know I might need for Tableau and
any calculations that I know that I'll
need to incorporate in my Tableau
dashboard and also make sure I save all
of those data files in a specific folder
again this is a very Bare Bones example
of what that data of what that dashboard
file our file might look like my project
but again any code to create anything
specific for Tableau goes there and all
the various files that I create
automatically get written into a special
Tableau use a special folder usually
just called for Tableau that lives in
that
you know projects working directory so
that means that when I actually need to
open Tableau again I just import all of
the data files in that one specific
folder and then I can use Tableau for
what Tableau is really good at
admittedly which is you know efficiently
making like really beautiful and
interactive data visualizations that fit
with you know the it infrastructure at
my organization
while leaving all the things I prefer to
do are any kind of data prep work
working joining data Etc leaving that in
R where I can more easily track it
and lastly um this might be shocking to
some of you depending on the type of
role that you are in
um but not all of us have access to git
or some kind of Version Control
um I don't
unfortunately and So within my data prep
data analysis files any files where I'm
kind of writing code making decisions
about data I have a lot of comments
and provide more comments than a lot of
people but if I don't have access to the
collaboration and communication benefits
of Version Control I need to do that
collaboration and communication
somewhere and for me it's just easiest
within my workflow to use dated comments
in my data profiles
so I comment any type of major decisions
that get made and you can also really
just in the comments link to any kind of
supporting documentation again whether
that's an internal key or even as
something as simple as referencing like
a March 25th email chain you had with
Ames where you decided to change the
definition of some Metric
um now I know there is a world theory
out there to you so some of you this
might seem like well that's a lot of
comments
um I won't show you in a while just not
to scare you
um because I know there's a theory out
there that if your code has common your
code isn't clear enough that code is
only clear enough when it doesn't need
any comments to explain what's going on
and that might be a perfectly valid you
know philosophy working Theory to have
at some organization in some setups but
if you don't have Version Control
and I certainly don't want you know
multiple versions of my data prep files
floating around
um I need to use comments in order to
communicate and collaborate with myself
or with someone else or more likely
myself in six months
and so to that I would really again
what's kind of underlined on the bottom
of the screen name is focus on what's
realistic for your solution even if it
might not be
um I guess commonly supported practice
what people think is ideal for the
general population this is ideal for
everyone does not mean that um like it
works for you
so given that
there are only struggles they're just
you know demonstrated just a handle of
the ones that I personally have had to
come up with techniques in order to face
they're definitely
challenges but I would argue really the
benefits greatly outweigh those
challenges and I'm going to go through
just a couple of examples of things I
have found in my work as kind of the
sole order to have kind of the highest
Leverage
the work that I do
and that's mostly because that's mostly
leveraging the benefits of our
how easily it can ease the burden of
repeated recording again if that's a
feature of your job and again
um easily transfer and hold
institutional knowledge
and so the first
um again biggest Leverage
win that I have is through the
development of internal packages
um if you don't know as I didn't know
kind of started our packages do not need
to be public they do not need to live on
GitHub
private packages that only that are only
for you or only for your team and they
can live on a shared Drive there's ways
to export your package to a shared drive
and packages are incredibly useful for
having easy access to Common data sets
that you use across multiple projects
also for documenting data definitions
and calculations and we can probably all
agree that documentation is a near
Universal problem and I cannot promise
that um this bullet point and having
data definitions in your internal
package will like solve that issue at
your organization
but whether you you know your
organization uses like a different
Enterprise tool or internal wikis
um
it is also really nice to have those
data definitions and calculations like
right at the fingertips of people who
are using them when they're using them
um so again all the entire data
documentation problem but it can help
solve it at the very small micro level
even if that's just you in your team and
documenting the data fields functions
Etc that you use
on a frequent basis
and lastly kind of the most common thing
we think think about what packages are
for are just packaging together
functions right so very easy of course
an internal package to track any common
analysis functions that you use as well
as ggplot themes again just as a
specific example I obviously do a lot of
data analysis and a small but frequent
part of my job is when people
asked me for
um to run analysis and create thoughts
that other people use to present
now I prefer to do my presentations in
Porto uh the Provost of my Porto even
though how cool would that be
um and so they obviously use power why
pretty frequently again get asked to run
rerun certain analyzes to create a plot
that someone can drop into PowerPoint
presentations
and thanks to my package I have several
ggplot themes include one that is
specifically for plots created for
PowerPoint presentations my theme has
you know my University's fonts and
colors it has the font sizes that I know
really well for PowerPoint presentation
and I can again very easily attach to
plots that I create
and I can really easily generate all of
those plots save them in a specific
place and even track and use the specs
that I know again work these specs work
perfectly for me with my themes to
create plots that look cohesive and look
appropriately sized in the PowerPoint
templates that we use
so again just a very small specific
example of how using the features of
internal packages has really saved me a
ton of time over the years
likewise also being able to leverage
parameterized reporting with our
markdown in portrait which I'm going to
slightly use interchangeably in this
example But whichever one you use or
move toward using as we all know so
great because there are so many output
formats including Microsoft Office
software formats if that's something
that you need or use
and any kind of parameterized reporting
being able to leverage that within our
markdown is so useful if you have again
any type of combinations of code text
plots data any varying parameters again
if repeated reporting is any part
of your job I'm guarantee that you'll be
able to find some efficiencies through
parameterized reporting
again just through one example let's say
you have an R markdown file that creates
a PDF report that has some text and some
plots and some tables
and you know that you need to create
this report every year for let's say
each division that you oversee or that
your group overseas
we can use the render function within
our markdown to specify you know where
these files should be saved how they
should be titled
and then you know use a little bit of
functional programming
and render that our markdown file for a
given year for let's say every unique
value of division within your data set
and just that you know few lines of code
makes it extremely easy to turn one our
markdown file into a whole bunch of PDF
files again saving tremendous amounts of
time I have a few of these simple
projects that I have to run for reports
that get
run a couple times a year for in my case
you know dozens of departments and
having to do that manually or
quasi-manually through Tableau or word
or kind of other system is just not
nearly as efficient as doing it in our
markdown
so I would argue that we have there are
for sure struggles again to I'm not
going to pretend that it's totally
smooth sailing if you are the only
person using r or your workplace and
trying to kind of fit R into
an existing workflow but hopefully I
have demonstrated that the benefits of
using R again even if you only use
specific bits and pieces
um of r
to solve whatever specific problems that
you face even if you can't use again an
entire R workflow is worth
um overcoming whatever specific
struggles you might face because it's
true that the less time you spend
reproducing your own analysis again I
have been in that place where you open
an Excel file from last year and you
should remember everything that you did
but don't and because it's Excel it's
not you know recorded very well it's not
reproducible that is just wasted time
having to reproduce your own analysis on
any time interval is really time wasted
that could more easily be made much more
efficient with arm
and so the less time you spend doing
that the more time you have for whatever
work it is a line of work that you find
important that you are uniquely good at
that you are able to you know put your
specific skills toward
so hopefully this talk has inspired you
to again continue to incorporate bits
and pieces of R into your existing
workflow even if you can't use all of
our like you see other people use and I
hope it has comforted you
um that not everyone uses the entire
our ecosystem A to Z
um that doesn't mean that you aren't a
real programmer you aren't a real coder
um as long as you're working kind of
within the constraints of your job
you can still find ways to use R to help
ease some of your specific problems
uh thank you again hopefully there are
time for questions
um but if not I will be in the
um I will be in the Discord and server
this afternoon
thank you